Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Jeremy
from Cincinnati, Ohio. Jeremy, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: A David, long time
listener, first time caller, thank you.
So I live near University of Cincinnati and
they just today implemented or announced a
covid vaccine mandate. OK, a lot of people, I
guess, pissed about it, but I'm definitely glad
because I'm going to live in an area where most
everyone's vaccinated. Right. Let's my friend
goes to Liberty University and they actually just
shut down from how bad their outbreak is. I saw
that all of his very dumb friends who don't have
the vaccine are super sick, which is like super
tragic. But like, what would you expect?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I read about that. I read
about Liberty University having
to shut down because of a covid,
highly infected university, I guess we could say.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think, you know,
it tends to happen with when you
put a lot of conservatives together,
Speaker 1: it can spread that way. Yeah.
Speaker 3: So what do you think about,
like vaccine mandates? Have you has your
opinion shifted on this at all or are you still
kind of not for them?
Speaker 1: Are you saying
government vaccine mandates or just schools and
businesses and and places airlines requiring them,
Speaker 3: I guess government
vaccine mandated? Yeah, I
Speaker 1: am the the reason I'm hesitant, I
don't think there's any legal issue with a with a
government mandated vaccine. I think it would more
likely be the state government. I think the legal
precedent from what I've read, I'm not an expert
myself, but I've read some scholarship on this.
I think the precedent favors states mandating
the vaccine rather than the federal government.
But I think the political backlash it would cause
may not be worth it. And you can achieve almost
the same thing. If we had like, for example. Forty
one percent of anti vaccines said if vaccines were
required to fly domestically, they would get
vaccinated. That's forty one percent. A lot of
people want to be able to get on an airplane.
So I think we get a much less controversially
achieve almost the same thing. If we had
schools requiring it, businesses requiring
it for employees, airlines requiring it to fly
and and it would be far less controversial.
I mean, just imagine what will happen if
Joe Biden were to say everyone must now
be vaccinated. It will be a political storm.
And I don't know how much more you get done
then if you do the things I'm talking about.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's very fair and very true,
I didn't really think about the political
backlash of it. I guess they're already even
trying to impeach him. So, yeah, that probably
wouldn't be good indeed. And then just one
more question for you. So I really enjoyed your
chest streams. Are we going to see more of them?
Speaker 1: Yeah, potentially. Potentially.
It's just been so busy lately with a lot
of different things. You know, we've been I
was traveling and then we have been building
out the bunker for security purposes and, you
know, all these different things. So but I do
hope to get back to some just dreaming.
Speaker 3: Awesome. Well, thanks for
taking my call. I'm a huge fan.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks,
Jeremy. Appreciate it. Hmm. Very good.
Jeremy from Cincinnati, very, very nice call